こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
24時間バスケの試合
生活したらどうなるのー
というわけでですねバスケットボールの
試合というものがあるんですよなんか10
分で1コーターってんですけどもそれを4
セットでタイマーとか止まるから大体1
時間ぐらいが1試合っていうんですけども
それを24時間やったらどうなるのかと
いうのを今回やってみたいと思いますいつ
もの24時間制が全部1人でやってるん
ですけども1人ではできないということで
今回この
YouTuberさんお呼びしております
どうぞ
[拍手]
よろしくお願いしまーすこの
企画もう5対5なんですよ結局これからも
バスケをできる
ベイクレさん5人で好奇臭かなと思って
今回
試作
申し訳ない
それは本当にどうなるかがわかんない
足をつるやつのは絶対出てくるんですよ
肉離れとか行くとちょっともう企画中断
まであるのかなと思います
[音楽]
直近でスケボーで怪我してちょっと走れ
ない
走れ
視聴者の皆さん
俺が歩く最後の姿になります
グッチの場所入ってきたんで人権
勝負っていうのもじゃああるってほぼない
というかどっちかちょっと協力して試合を
24時間成立させるというのが
普通にやってましたけど
本当に1日2世紀限界なんですね
今回なんと24試合
ということで
僕も普段畑とかでやってるんでちょっと下
に準備したんで
よろしくお願いします
[拍手]
ないんで畑のメンバーも来てくれてるので
ひょっとしたら抗体とかも全然でここから
です普通に24時間バス消しても企画には
なるんですけどはいどうせだったらあの
休みたいじゃないですか皆さん
というわけであの僕24時間生活するとき
によくつけてる最高の出るというものを
つけております
これ何かというと3時間に1回サイコロ
振れます
合計7回サイコロで出た目に応じて皆さん
にボーナスというか休憩などがあります
ね最後の1が出た時は1時間
2対2になります
[拍手]
各チームに2人2人選抜してもらって
残りのメンバーは全員1時間休みです
これで個人の能力を高めてください22が
出た時は次の最後のフルマンの3時間
走るの禁止です今
結構当たったらみんな嬉しい
3番3番が出たら1時間
全員気絶します
ついで4番
なしです
続いて5番5番出たら3時間ハーフコート
の試合になります
投票に結構縮まるからそして
66が出たらもう1回振ったサイコロの出
た目の数の人数が3時間休憩です2
回目振って1が出たらじゃんけんが何かし
て
両チームの中から1名だけ3時間休憩
6寝たらあのまあその6人をどう決めるか
また話し合いましょう
という
感じで得点の人数が3時から休めるよと
いう
シンプルなルールを言うと24秒ルールは
なしです
そして3時間に1回今言ったサイコロが
振れますタイムアウト1時間に各チーム1
回ずつ取ります
あるじゃんなのでちゃんとハーフタイムと
かもございます試合の中で
12時間経過したタイミングでハーフ
タイムが30分14時間12時間後に8
タイムが来るんでそこで30分休憩所とお
昼休憩とか12時間持って朝9時
ですそこでちょっとご飯休憩として
もらおうかなそれ以外はサイコロがあるん
で
ぜひやってみましょう
皆さんよく考えてみてください24時間
体育館借りて試合できる環境よくできたと
思いませんか今回ですね
誰でも気軽に参加できる大会を運営して
いる
dブックさんのご協力でできております
[拍手]
概要欄からチェックしてみてください
[音楽]
はじめしゃちょー情報によるとあの靴紐は
グルメットにすると
すべて多分ついてそうだ
ゆるくしていかにふわふわっと乗り切るか
なと
俺たちこのまま1回のシュート打たずつ
俺たちもいいんじゃない
全然やってないけどいいの
チュートレンとか
はい
としては
言うて勝ちたいわけよ
本当に多分体力持たないから
極力手を抜いて締めるとか閉めて
リラックスしながら乗り切りましょう
得点女
得点を目指します
絶対慣れないよマジ
怖いっす
24時間後
素敵な笑顔にして終わろう
[拍手]
頑張りましょう
やりましょうかさあ準備が整いました
いよいよ24時間バスケの試合生活が
始まろうとしています
皆さん後輩の皆さんスタッフの皆さん本当
にごめんなさい巻き込んでですが今笛が
鳴りましたもう誰にも止められません
こいつらは24時間バスケをし続けなけれ
ばならない
握手を肩役忙しいお互い24時間頑張ろう
生き残ろうと
心に固く
決意をそしてティップオフ試合が始まり
ましたここから24時間タイマーが動き
出すこのタイマーを24時間止まりません
普通にでもバンクの試合をするだけなので
普通にしばらくはバスケの仕上げて楽しん
でください
次の習慣からバスケが始まりました
ねなんでこんなことしようと思ったのか
なお確認社長に
移って終了
決まったーはじめしゃちょーの
ミドルシュートから試合が動き出しました
マジでちょっと何で俺これしようとしたん
だろうでもどうなっちゃうんだろうって
思いましたね24時間バスケをした後の
人間の
状態
あとは乗せるポイントが忘れた2外れて
再び始めチームになります
初めて今白いユニフォームを着てるのが
全員ですよねでカラフルな変な人たちが
ネイティブチェンですおっと外れた
もう1回おっとっと
[拍手]
探しのドリブルで進んでいきます
ナイスカットです
体力を使わずに試合を進めていくかって
いうのもポイントになりそうですねこれ
[音楽]
さあそして食べ始めチーム
走れっぱなしなんだよね基本的に
バスケット
毎月バスサーベのシュート外れた友や
ドリブルで
再び自分の
運命
ドリブル技術がえげつないここパス
博士に戻し
私がドリブルして
長いパス
ナイスカットですと思ったら
目の前のシュート外れた
んでね行ったり来たりとバスケット
シュートに
惜しい
まだでも結構軽くやってます正直
このペーサー持たない
ロングパス1人で走んなきゃいけないの
いやその通りなんて俺を走りたくないけど
バスで出されたら走るしかない
ドリブル技術あんまり
走らされる
体力持たないからいかにこう
みたいなところもありますこの辺の
ドリブルです
繋がってステロイの主がない
[音楽]
やっぱ決めて
今のところは楽しいんじゃないですか皆
さんきっと
普通に楽しいバスケットボールしてると
思いますが
[音楽]
10分経過しました
疲れはまだ大丈夫だと思います
素晴らしいナイスバスえげつない
黒い男色
ここでタイムアウトです
今は
ここで差をつけようと言っているともや
うまい何だそのパーツは見たことないぜ
さあ圭介がドリブルで持ってドリブルもう
1回したダブルドリブルだ
ドリブルスターターもっとドリブルしたら
ダメだ違反ですそれは
見てるよー今回に限ったことじゃない
ですか
健介はダブルドリブのルールがまだ理解
できないみたいです
素晴らしいバス
ナイスペロー
しっかりと助けナイスシュート
[音楽]
来週だいいですね
これは3ポイント入っていく
うわー走らせる申し訳ないが決めてくれ
ナイスシュート
さんが取って触るがちょっとぶん投げる
地獄のようなパスだおっとっと何にも
ぶつかっていないが伸ばしてしまう大丈夫
かこれおや大丈夫かちょっと痛そうですが
これ大丈夫そうですか
[音楽]
魔法のこととかあの言葉を聞いたら何でも
できるようになるのか怖いですがナイス
シュート社長
ちょっと怖いなさい
です
智也のパスカルのテロこのラインが結構僕
強そうですね
ドリブルでミドルジャンプシュート
探しのスリーポイント
決まっていく
[音楽]
心配させてまたどんどんふわっといた
シュートをしっかりと決める
上からの
ナイスシュート
下がっての3ポイント
美しいこれ
持つかちょっとね
フェイントで完全に引っかかっても何も
分かってないサーベルどこ見てるんだ
リバウンドを取って再び走らされるはじめ
しゃちょー
これがさせるのきついなあ
そういう感じで仕上がって進んでいきます
[音楽]
シュート
外れて取ってもう一度おっとこれは接触が
あったかシュート前のファール
フリースロですあれ大丈夫かはじめしゃ
ちょー
怪我しているようですね腕が痛いかこれ
ひどいですがフリースローこれ休めるん
ですよ
[音楽]
そうフリースルは5カウント中に打てば
いいので結構
試合が止まるので
休めますみんなしっかりと
僕を使って休んでいきますが試合が動き
出すともやんドリブルで切り込んでいく
すごい体力だ
いやーこれねただ点差は結構チーム始め
強いんですよ今のところ
じゃここで2回目のタイムアートです
さあ40分経過したところで再び試合が
動いてきますもう基本的にほんと真面目に
試合してる感じですね
転写もそんな超開くわけでもなくやっぱ
10点差ぐらいを行き来してる感じです
ただしナイス中ですさあ時間がそろそろ1
時間経過しようとしています
[音楽]
聞いたことのない数字です
バスケットボールにおいて23時間頑張り
ましょう
地獄です
さあドリブルで左から切り込んでシュート
これではじめしゃちょーチーム100点目
か100点できましたね
ま1時間で100点ぐらい入ったという
計算になるんでしょうか100
[音楽]
点突破です
結構試合が減ってるんだよなぁ
6点差とかいや2点差結構縮まってるん
ですよ先日普通にあの手が抜けない真面目
な死体が続いてます
ドリブルで
ドリブリここ決めたら
決めるか決まったその
手さん一転車ですまずただのいい試合が
ずっと行われています
先週離れてたらねなんかちょっとだなとも
できるんですけどもギリギリの種類が
ずっと続くから
結構ね
両チームメンタル的に使われてると思い
ますやっぱね
負けず嫌いな人が多いのでこの10人は
[音楽]
シュートでもう1回
ファールだありがとうございますあれ
誰も
フリースローの時いません
みんな多分
ベンチに帰って休憩とかしてるんでしょう
フリースローは
本当に
オアシスですそして主題歌の動きいたし
ますそして間もなく
しました
まだみんな走れてるんですよゴリゴリ2
時間経過ってことはこれ3試合目ぐらいっ
てとこですねまだ全然
動けてそうな感じはありますがそこそこを
まとめているはずの社長の
ナイスシュート
彗星もう3試合目って基本しないからね
あんまり
細やかパスカット
そしてパス建築ドリブルでその間を
吊り込んでいくかガチャピンブックの
カラーハーブですありがとう
まさにそれです
本当に試合が止まることが
彼らの命を作っている
謎の表情を見てください
結構
辛いんですよもうみんな
を取ってしております
しっかり
なんだその投げ方は
入る気がし
気を取り直して2投目おっと
ダメだ
試合が再び動き出します
さあここでタイムアウトです
失敗と休みに行きましょう
[音楽]
さあ
再び試合が動き出しました
見たことのない点数です200点は早々
行かないと思いますよバスケの試合で
2時間半が経過したところで相当もうね
もう
十分でしょってくらいで普通は
止まることなく
刻々と時間が進んでいきますそして
レイクルチーム200点いきましたねここ
で
ステップパスカットおっとここで接触
って濃い的なお知らせではないのか暴力は
やめていただきたいで足のブレーキが効か
ないんですよもう本当
足の方が来ていて
足をくぐったバスが伸ばしをなしに当たっ
てしまった方大丈夫かこれは
立ち上がれるか
ここで
でしょうか
まあそろそろ多分ね走ってる人とか出て
くるんでどうしますか
今の声は幻聴まもなく3時間ですね
休憩して無事復活できたみたいで再び試合
がしますここから始めちゃんのシュート
ナイス中としっかりと決めていきましょう
[音楽]
本当にそして間もなく3時間3時間付近
ですよこれ
外れて
3時間経過しましたお疲れ様です
いやもう終わりでしょ
限界より
あと21時間ありますかサイコロ
振っていきたいと思いますそれだけで出た
目でこれが起きるんですけどもま4はない
なと思いますよ僕はいや出したら
ね行か
せていただきます
[拍手]
10時間が人間の限界ですね
今
話しかけないでもらえますか